Hello, everybody.
My name is Markiplier,
and welcome to another
World's
Quietest
Let's Play.
Although,
the elegance of with which I play these games, will be countermanded by the fact that we are going to be playing...
Getting Over It
by the eminent douchebag known as Bennett Foddy.
Now as we peruse the world of Mr. Cauldron Man,
keep in mind...
I will not scream,
I will not rant,
I will not rave,
I will not allow myself to become the debased
asshole that you all know Markiplier to be.
I will not
be
stopped in my quest
Shut up,
Mr. Foddy.
Leave me to my own devices
as I climb up this mountain of bullshit that you have created.
You know what you've done
to deserve all the hate that you receive, and yet you stand...
like a titan among the mountain and you stare dow-
-oo- *long exhale*
I am entirely happy with my predicament because I am a paragon of virtue
and I know exactly what it takes to be the one who succeeds
when all others fail.
And you will  seeEeEEEeeEEE *Dark is starting to shine through*
*quantum detonation imminent*
*croak*
(Darkiplier 2k18) You will see the inside of your entrails when I drag them out of your abdomen and show them to you...
Mr. Cauldron Man.
If you even have legs, (I do)
(Darkiplier) I'll be certain to rip them off, and replace your arms with those legs, for all the good your arms are doing you, right now.
Excellent.
*INHALE*
*pained silence*
*mark.exe has stopped responding*
*toss*
(Priest Donald from The Game has possessed Mark) This is a representation of my SINNNNNS, and you will be purged in the fires of absolu-
*Mark stares in absolute disbelief of what happened*
*Whispers* You will be purged in the fires of absolution
along with all of your ilk...
I will burn the heretics that you are harboring inside of your soul...
(Darkiplier)*menacingly* I will destroy you.
I will never allow you to survive. I will never *inhale*
Ha ho ha he ha hoho
I. Will. Just. Breeeath...
Everything is calm, peaceful, rainbows, sunshine, and butterflies-
*INHALE*
PFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFT
I am a deflating balloon of anger.
I am a hot air balloon...
of sass.
And you will not prevent me *tiny inhale* from achie-
*huge inhale*
Fromachievingmyultimatevictory I will noOoOt allow you to be the one that
tosses me from the precipice of...
success.
*Chica impersonation*
*Wheezy voice* You see what happens when you obey me?!
Success rains down upon everybody.
The long, weary road of success...
is paved...
with failures.
And I will not...
be a ffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffff
FFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFF
(Mark's becoming a deflating.. Air-Balloon...??)
The tea is ready.
(Oh, a kettle. Heh. Of course.)
I have seen
your browser history
(Oh no)
and I am not impressed.
(FML)
*deep throating*
I don't know how that happened, I could...
*angry Mark sounds*
I know an impossibility when I see it,
and 'impossible' is written all over the face of this game.
Spilling over it-
OOOoooo0oooOOOO
I passed a kidney stone.
Please listen to me... once... more... you... sack... of... poopie...
I'm a calm peaceful man with calm peaceful intentions, (don't lie Mark)
who is going to get through this with strength of mind and strength of soul. (are you sure about that?)
Nope.
Nop- *INHALE*
*humpback whale* (told ya)
*cue Mark's attempt at going Super Saiyan*
*Ah, he's even got the pose I see..*
Nononono.
I see what you are doing, and I will not allow it.
I will take this patiently and I will take this graciously because I am a gracious, patient man. (we know that you are not that)
I am the graciest, patientiest man ever known to the face (stop lying)
of the aaaages.
Hat. Help. HGGGH. Hat:Nope
(Darkiplier) Hat, you've betrayed me just like everyone else. You will burn in the fires of my own Hell,
(Darkiplier) and I will choose your pain to last eternity.
HAT. Do not betray me. Get out of here.
You will know everything that is-
gUh- nn- MMMMM-
(Darkiplier) I HAVE CLUNG TO DEEPER CONVICTIONS THAN YOU WILL TRY TO WREST FROM MY SOUL.
*Spontaneously good at the game*
*Spontaneously good at the game + Confusiplier*
Uh...
*Confusiplier*
Right,
*acts confident*
just as I planned.
Excellent, I have reached the mountain, the zenith, the aperture, the epicenter.
Everything has (sudden phone ding) led to this moment, and I will not be dissuaded now by my phone, not by this...
mountain, not by the things that are trying to stop me, nothing will- *chokes*
get in my way, not this final zenith, this final moment, this one...
unquestioning obstacle will stop... being... douche... and will obey. It will obey. (Are you sure about that?)
Every undulating face...
nnNnNo... nno... no... nHNnnn! (Told ya)
*cue Mark's attempt to go Super Saiyan 2* (Silly Mark, you are not a saiyan)
("Goin' Down the Road Feeling Bad" plays to further taunt Mark into insanity)
*Mark silently cries while Cliff Carlisle yodels*
Alas,
I leave you now, to go slumber amongst the ancients..
*faint sound of outro music*
Thank you again,
and as always, I will see you in the next video.
Buh-Bye....
*Outro plays*
*Ends*